la matinée l'écomusée du pays de rennes
est un bel exemple de mémoire populaire
c'est un livre vivant de notre histoire
et en ce mois de novembre c'est à la
fête du pot mais qui étaient conviés les
visiteurs le pot mais c'est une
tradition mais vous allez voir aussi une
recette
le pot mais avait mijoté toute la nuit
on pouvait enfin de goûter cet après
midi à l'écomusée de la matinée à rennes
tradition vingtaine de poneys une sorte
de confiture faite à partir de pommes
douces et de cidre nouveau la recette de
base varie selon les lieux où les
familles mais chaque cuisson nécessite
environ 200 litres de cidre et 100 kg de
pommes le mélange essence est tourné à
l'aide de ribot et le faut mais est cuit
quand on arrive aux siens de l'oulle
dans la bassine autrefois éléments
importants de l'alimentation en campagne
dans les familles pauvres qui le
consomme est sur du pain ou des galettes
le pommé est aujourd'hui prétexte à des
chants des danses et des comptes qui
accompagne sa longue et lente hui sont
plus rapides à réaliser un autre pot mes
gâteaux traditionnels de la région de
saint malo
les pommes font toujours là mais une
pâte feuilletée rentre là cette fois la
galette ou la tartine secrets de la
légèreté laisser reposer la pâte et la
tour et quatre fois se reposer la pâte
en deux chaque jour
avant tout recettes familiales le pommé
est encore préparé dans quelques
pâtisseries à saint-coulomb paul
chevalier fait dépôt mais comme son père
les faisait unique entorse à la
tradition les pommes des rouges et de
john idéal pour le pommé sont épluchées
à la machine ne les connaissez pas donc
la région a baissé
il abaisse à 19h avant dernière étape de
la préparation les pommes d'écraser sont
étalés sur un fond de pâte sucrée est
recouverte
le tout est mis au four pendant 20
minutes reste alors à le déguster encore
tiède
c'est en tout cas comme cela que loïc
mathieu le frère